time we checked in with findlay
automotive group the sponsors of this
next segment they were competing for
best buddies champion
well how's it going rocky stopped by one
of their fundraisers to find out
[Music]
it is a family affair finley family
affair here how are you guys doing hey
we are celebrating our champion of the
year i know he's not deemed champion of
the year yet but michelle he's our
champion of the year right heck yeah
heck yeah so what is champion of the
year tyler tell everybody okay so we're
raising money for best buddies great
local charity that helps people with
developmental disabilities and michelle
works for us and she came to us through
best buddies and she came and asked me
to run for champion of the year so
that's what we're doing and today we're
doing one of our fundraisers which is a
dunk tank we're letting
all of our dealerships throw in a little
money the people coming to get the dunk
me and some of the other managers so
it's a great
great little bonding experience i guess
i get a little win and uh and we're
raising some money and it's all going to
culminate with the best buddies champion
beer gala on november 5th and we're
hoping to raise the most money we're
hoping actually to raise not just the
most money here but the most money
nationally that's what we're trying to
do wow okay so what do you have to do to
raise the most money nationally tell
everybody how we can help well so people
can go to the best buddies
web page and they can find
where they can donate to our campaign so
we'd love to have you do that we're uh
we're thinking that we can
raise a lot of money that way but we're
also doing some fundraisers like this uh
which is the uh the dunk tank and we're
getting all of our vendors and sponsors
involved so
lots of ways people can help but mainly
just go on and donate on the web page if
they would there you go and michelle
just tell us one more time why he is
your champion of the year
okay the reason why i
choose a nominee title is because he's
amazing person he loves people with
people with disabilities
and i know he's going to win
and
we have people right behind us cheering
for him
oh man you got us you got us right there
but now it's time to get really loud and
excited for the dunk tank because that
is why you're wearing those flowers i i
don't i don't want to drown so i got the
floaties i got my goggles you know
safety first tyler this feels so wrong
but it's so fun
and really the goggles really set off
the look all right
[Music]
[Applause]
first shot that is unbelievable that's
right
oh you didn't even hit the board
[Music]
hey thanks again to findlay automotive
for sponsoring this segment will be